awesome hey everyone we are back at the
blockchain economic forum we are now
talking to telly Valeri Onew thanks for
coming out of the show greatly
appreciate it
and I actually got to hang out with
McKenzie slaughter your partner your
co-founder yes at beyond Capital Markets
that was a blast I love talking to her
at blushing for social justice and I
learned so much I'm excited to continue
learning from you yes so global
infrastructure for financial impact so
teach us about what you're up to
we'd love to learn okay well um as a few
people who I met today kept asking me so
what is an impact project and that's the
key question which was trying to solve
so we found that there is a huge gap
between impact investing or people
understanding what impact investing is
and actual finance so there's a big
capital gap and it's and a lot of times
I have to explain to people that impact
is actually spread across different
asset classes but the issue is a lot of
times when people think of impact they
think about just social impact they
think about this philanthropy you know
aid for trade and the you know handouts
you know and and just doing something so
you feel good that's just a very small
component of it and that doesn't really
generate any returns however we see
impact very differently from all totally
different lens
you know impact for me or us isn't just
social impact impact can be
transformative you know so I live in an
emerging market so if you were to
provide finance you live in I live and
think it's a Nevis that's in the Eastern
Caribbean so for anyone who's listening
it's in the Eastern Caribbean West
Indies I'm sure you've heard of Antigua
or you know Barbados where one of the
Lesser Antilles
Islands its it is independent so it has
its own governance structure has its own
Prime Minister and everything else and
we also have it depends on tourism and
financial services so it also hosts one
of the one of the biggest international
financial services center as well yes
sir I really small but wait global I
want to ask you some questions about
saying kids can I on the way ask you a
couple questions
so how many people live there it's about
fifty to five thousand people fifty five
thousand people live on this island
and this island in the Caribbean is
about the size of you know how many
square miles issue this or square
kilometers I'm the worst person to ask
the most come on does this need to drive
across the island hour and a half to
drive across the island oh my god around
the island so this is a very small Wow I
don't have okay Island because it's sink
it's and the sister island is Nevis
Saint Kitts and Nevis yeah together
population is about 55,000 they're about
I'm sure it's it's increased over time
are the waters just light blue and
beautiful awesome beautiful you look at
me like you have no idea what you're
missing
honeymoon right 24 hours 65 so how is
the house like the quality of life there
like is the is the you know the house
the house the food how how do people
have a job like a meaning or purpose in
life
I was like the health care very well
interestingly um think it's a Nevis is
actually listed as a high-income country
it's one of the very few if not only
high-income country avidly Caribbean is
second to Monaco in terms of the highest
number of billionaires living and think
it's that being said while it's a
high-income country most like other
emerging markets it would have some
pockets of you know areas where you
could improve upon yeah like job
creation
and so on we have quite a young
population very young population and as
with most young populations they're
looking for more and new opportunities
to grow and develop
so when I speak about impact these are
the type of things I see where you have
you know just as simple if you were to
provide finance to a company a smaller
company or a start-up in a small island
like Milan and they were to grow to the
size of I don't know a Facebook or
Google or even something even medium it
doesn't have to be that huge by hiring
like maybe 10% of the population and you
know that would have a trickle-down
effect in terms of improving likelihood
so right now the the lifestyle is pretty
good it could be improved because it
doesn't trickle down to like the whole
population so you still have those
issues but if you have projects that can
provide that access to capital it can
then trickle down to more and as I said
before you have a very young population
that they're into music they're very
very creative Oh sweets
that's a gap sounds like my peeps yeah
but there's a gap yeah access to finance
yeah you know and and to foster their
creative potential to the fullest so
maybe tell us just maybe like one little
last bit about what like what's the
language that spoken English primary
what's the secondary English interesting
okay I mean it was one of the former
British colonies as part of the British
Commonwealth so it's English and well
locally in the island people do speak
dialect which is like broken English
English okay and we you're hosting
something cool there that's upcoming
yeah can we know about that is that sure
so next week from the 25th to the 30th
we partnered with the think it's music
festival this festival has been going on
for nearly 30 years and it gets bigger
and bigger every single year so this
year we decided to do a little
differently so they normally have this
think it's festival and what we decided
to do was to bring in that component of
blockchain and crypto to it so because
we focused on soso music festival really
kicks off on the 27th right up to the
30th so from the 25th we have a whole
session we have two days of an impact
investing summit very high-level we have
as one of our lead sponsors our catalyst
sponsor is Bitcoin dot-com and we have a
grace with Roger Vere who was one of the
first if not the first investor in
blockchain and Bitcoin and you know
crypto projects on a hole so he'll be
sharing his insights on how he got into
the space and how he supports innovation
holistically and if our viewers continue
supporting us on patreon we can afford
to maybe go down to Saint Kitts and join
an interview and an interview some
brilliant people down there we would
love for you to join us so hook it up
homies if you honestly get down there
thank you just a quick plug yeah we're
trying to we're we'll have the link in
the bio to come and check them out as
well so you know we're not just going to
be talking about blockchain for good
that's just a lot of superficial stuff
we're really talking about how to bridge
the gap yes so we have the first two
days focused on impact investing will
have potential crypto fund managers we
also offer programs with to support and
develop crypto fund managers we'll be
announcing the launch of our exchange
which is going to be the first
decentralized exchange for an impact
mm-hmm
so this is really serious it's going to
be big and we have some really strong
partners on it we're also building we're
going to be launching shortly after that
is our protocol which is the protocol to
support crypto traders so if you're
interested in becoming a crypto fund
manager and you want to also
I learn how to become a crypto fund
manager in the impact space yes we
actually have an entire protocol an
infrastructure to provide the tools and
so on I mean we had a session today
talking about how to set up a crypto fun
and you know we heard a cough like over
a hundred thousand in the US so we
managed to kind of bring down the costs
and make it easier for a new crypto fund
managers to come up and we really
believe in finance I think the big gap
is the big gap is we need to get more
people finance there are a lot of young
people who are looking for opportunities
and looking for opportunities in finance
that's true yeah and Millennials are
very should I say social conscious yes
so here is a here is an opportunity
where you can bridge the gap with
leveraging your your your passion for
social consciousness with something that
actually brings high returns high
financial returns where you can actually
see track impact you know where you're
seeing job creation you're actually
seeing economies grow and thrive and all
of this is tracked very transparently
low cost on the blockchain okay well
let's unpack this because ok first first
things first you'll be launching your
decentralized exchange for social impact
and then you'll be also starting to help
train crypto fund managers and social
impact space which is very exciting like
you said more people especially socially
conscious young people need to get
involved in understanding how they can
potentially assist with this whole
crypto decentralization social impact
revolution ok so in order for us to do
all of that so it's all launching and
then you're tracking it you said via via
the blockchain so you're tracking how
many jobs are made how well off people
are doing after you guys have made an
initial social investment so maybe teach
us a bit about this so we have partnered
with EXO foundation out of South Africa
X
so that's IXO and you just a bit about
that yeah so XR they're really huge on
building they're building out their
protocol for tracking impact for
tracking impact so they they basically
are creating a whole taxonomy framework
on the blockchain and this is really key
because you can't you can't begin to
throw money at something you can't
measure yes and I think that's the big
big gap so when you look at even even
when you look at traditional you know
should I say impact companies or
development organizations like the
multilateral ones like the World Bank
and so on and they fund projects one of
the big things is how do you monitor the
project how do you evaluate it and how
can you get the results it needs to be
results based so the challenge we've
always had is the fact that impact is
linked and related to different many
different criteria many different
indicators all right
yeah it's linked to many different
indicators yes and every project is
different so it so has a big task and
they're creating a whole taxonomy
library to kind of document all of this
so we're partnering with them and this
is this has this now has when you're at
you're thinking about it's not just
tracking the impact but now we can
actually move into developing new
financial products like social impact
bond bonds green bonds because you can
track you know what you can measure
effectively you can fund you know
basically so it's gonna create a whole
new unlocking a whole new perspective
for for finance so ok so I XOXO was
making it to the taxonomy for social
impact measurements and then they're
still doing that so you've partnered
with them we're going to they will be
not just our partner for providing that
level of transparency onto the exchange
but then together we'll be launching
some smart impact bonds interesting so
what does a let's ask two-part question
here what does the smart impact bond
look like how does it work and then also
also follow-up to that is how how give
us an example of how the social impact
variables that are measured over time
Ultimo change so I think first of all
maybe to break down what a what an
impact bond would look like is really
looking at the underlying assets so
let's just take into an example carbon
on carbon credits there is a particular
market for carbon credits so let's just
say you as a person your your you
probably have a lot of let's look at
vehicles so let's say you have a lot of
your vehicle uses up a lot of gas not
only that it it turns out a lot of
emissions and the emissions are high
we know the emissions damage the
environment and cause a lot of the
global climate change you're seeing
right now so now if you were to get
another type of vehicle maybe a electric
one you're actually going to be reducing
that carbon emission now you can
actually take that certificates because
you can you now have something to
measure so it's a verification document
on the block scene to say this is what
you've done
first you were wasting maybe 60,000 or
whatever the measurement is but now
you're able to replace that by you know
using an electric vehicle now we could
take that create our certificates on the
blockchain and then tokenize it organize
it so so then what does when I gain
tokens based on the amount of social
impact that I make exact how do I spend
those tokens inside your home ago on the
exchange so the exchange exchange really
it's like any normal exchange where you
could trade the tokens but each of those
tokens is linked to an impact asset okay
so then the impact asset you just
grabbed was about switching over to
vehicle use that is more environmentally
a carbon credit certificate and I get
token that's one of many yes exactly you
could maybe even get one for coming in
and teaching kids in school it's an
education certified that's not just just
teaching them but maybe we have an
indicator showing that they have learned
so the knowledge transfer is all the
tricks just about teaching you know
everyone got to do the knowledge
transfer part of it is if we can track
the knowledge transfer and you know you
have a baseline of where they were
before where they were after and that
has changed their behavior that perhaps
could be tokenized
on it so yes you're you're literally
then purchasing tokens and by purchasing
tokens and trading them you're actually
providing impact so okay so now we have
tokens because we've made social impact
now we go to the exchange and we take
our tokens and then we exchange the
tokens for other either other tokens
other cryptocurrency
we have that whole infrastructure to
facilitate awesome awesome so is this is
this the there seems to be a lot of
projects right now that are working on
social impact tokens and things like
that
but not the exchange like you're like
you're saying a lot of projects that
we've noticed even when I was here at BS
they have some fantastic projects that
are really really focused on impacts
like I saw a robotics project where they
they actually teach robotics and they
bring in the equipment and I mean that's
huge for STEM education yes I talked
about building a whole new generation of
Engineers that is very impactful yes
have also on another side I saw box lab
and they're doing something very
different they're supporting small
medium enterprise
kind of navigate the whole block chain
dimension and they help them with
penetration testing for cybersecurity
because normally you they can't afford
to secure themselves so they're
providing that and they're leveraging
the technology so all of those projects
provide different types of impact yep
yeah those are just examples of impact
we have one in our portfolio of they're
based in Nigeria called Agra plexi
they're providing finance reformers yes
and we all know across this is not
something unique to Nigeria or East
Africa West Africa to the Caribbean all
over maybe not in the US but smaller
farmers generally do not have access to
finance mm-hmm
smaller farmers can also get their whole
yields wiped out by weather
there are so many variables that go into
the small farms that are really
important to actually calculate in the
especially in the process of trying to
maximize their potential so okay so you
so we've listed so many awesome examples
this is I mean it's making me really
think hard about how we can ascribe
tokens to social impact and get people
incentivized it's sent about yes and and
like I said there is that's why I don't
particularly like the terminology social
knowledge the terminology is oceanology
social because social impact first is a
small component of impact I prefer the
terminology impact innovation impact
innovation I like that because you also
have innovations that can create
transformative impact yeah I mean I mean
maybe not the Facebook's but I mean
Google before before there was anything
like search you know they weren't there
and then they provided some new
innovation and now people literally live
on Google to do all their search and
stuff so
for information they're providing impact
of your transparency at their level but
now you have an opportunity of creating
more impact so that's just an example of
a one company that that's doing a small
thing in terms of bridging the gap with
information asymmetry
now when you now take that context to
other different sectors and you you you
add what decentralize technologies could
do with added layers of transparency
it's it's phenomenal you know so so it
would be you're talking about taking
something like one of the massive
conglomerates like Google or Facebook
and adding layers of trans transparency
through decentralization so teach us
about maybe this is actually I mean a
lot of times people go to blockchain
events and they listen and they hear it
but they don't quite understand what's
really happening but what it is is they
decentralize what the technologies or
blockchain actually enable you to have
multi-sided networks
it's a multi-sided network model mm-hmm
and if you look at like the ubers the
Airbnb and Google they have what we call
double-sided platforms so all all this
enables you to do is to create a
platform model but it's a multi-sided
platform model meaning the network
effects a even more than just a
double-sided network and does the
double-sided network mean that there is
hoover that provides the software and
then the the drivers that provide the
cars and then there's the customer and
the you have much more people in the
ecosystem so right now if you're looking
at uber you have the drivers on the one
side and then you have the the
passengers but I imagine an ecosystem
where you can incentivize the drivers
the passengers and other stakeholders
that aren't even part of the ecosystem
maybe along the whole chain you'd be
like the city and everybody gets
incentivized
you know you then have
what what was what was supposed to be
the whole objective of the internet and
the whole building your community of
value you now have a full community of
value but I love that community
community value and I'm sure saying kids
can do that easier than the us because
you have fifty fifty five thousand
people it's easier to do a tight-knit
social fabric then for three hundred
thirty million yeah so maybe we need to
start these the social impact processes
of in maybe smaller communities in like
the cities and towns that is true and
and you're very correct because we've
been working we've been working in the
ecosystem not just locally in saying
kids with the Caribbean holistically and
also some parts of Africa in terms of
building the ecosystem from ground up
yeah
it's very critical that you are
identified the different stakeholders
and players and one of the areas that we
have seen you know that is that gap is
that whole access to finance being that
glue the fabric it's broken the finance
we all know the financial you know
system is absolutely broken that's why
bitcoin was born but it's still there's
still much more to you know just
payments what about providing access for
inclusion and so on yes so this is the
type of infrastructure we're building
that infrastructure is starting from as
you say one community at a time you can
totally redesign and rebuild a whole
ecosystem so looking at what we're doing
say starting off with Nevis Nevis is
known as an international financial
center a jurisdiction where they offer
financial services now we have gone to
crypto finance why not build a whole new
fabric around crypto finance let's just
face it the traditional financial sector
is over Alec regulated and a lot of
times you know they're dying out you
know
it's not competitive anymore and they
really need new products and services to
thrive this gives them a competitive
edge by being able to facilitate even
people coming into their jurisdiction to
launch their projects build their
companies in a compliant way because
right now in the u.s. everything is
helter-skelter but just because you're
going offshore it doesn't mean you're
not going to be compliant they have
regulators in these jurisdictions it's
just that the policies and the
frameworks may not necessarily be
similar to what you're experiencing in
the US but yes it's an ecosystem where
you could launch but not just that not
just coming into the ecosystem
leveraging like traditional
international offshore you now have a
thriving young workforce talent
potential population that could also fit
into that so you know helping them
develop you do need service providers
and if you have more crypto hedge fund
managers coming out of that it's perfect
yes and you have an academy that's
training crypto fund managers which is
really exciting
you also talked about inclusion being
really important which it totally is
inclusion for opportunity to make sure
that all children born into the world
have the opportunities that they need
yes in order to maximize their own
potential in the potential of their
communities okay so a couple quick
questions as we come to towards the end
how about we ask you you've addressed
this a little bit throughout but I'm
still curious maybe what are you most
looking forward to with the
decentralization technologies what I'm
most looking forward to is just what you
said access and being able for people to
realize their full potential okay
it goes down to improving people's
livelihoods in a very sustainable manner
in a very transparent manner at a low
cost
while providing the type of liquidity
investors need it's fair fair game I
love it it's it's like it's like the
right recipe what just came out of your
mouth so the right recipe that we need
for providing opportunity
okay how about what do you think we
should do about wealth and equality
being exacerbated by exponential
technology it seems as though the very
very rich are getting much much richer
while them the poor are getting just
slightly richer so what do you think
about that and how does that relate to
globalization how do we how do we
balance that we are one mentality of a
geopolitical leadership correct you know
unfortunately globally you know all our
different ecosystems have created should
I say pockets of access points where
people have access to information
Mel King calls it the inner the the
internet highway well the information
information highway in that context so
you have pockets where people have not
really I think at the bottom of it is a
lack of access to inform II agree
lack of access to knowledge tools now
you've had you we have traditional
systems which was designed for the
Industrial Age it was really for very
specific industries and now we are in a
knowledge age where we now have to
provide more democratic access to
everyone so it's not just a matter of
okay you're trained or you go to this
particular school to do something all
the aldi should I say pillars for for
organizational pillars all lead to an
old antiquated framework so that has led
to this disparity that we're seeing
right now where you know some people had
access to education
some people had access to those networks
and they were further along than those
who haven't so while you know it might
be a utopia you know this like works it
might be a utopia to imagine everyone
being unloved
playing field but what we can do is try
and do what we can to bridge the device
and I think we're in a space where
digital allows us to do that but then
also if people don't have access and
don't have the knowledge it can also
widen that digital that that digital
opportunity can become a curse and
widening the disparity so unfortunately
there isn't an easy answer to this but
then I think as a conscious community we
do need to play a role and I think in
everything we do education is always at
the bottom of the pillar where you have
to your hearts cross-cutting you have to
and whatever you're doing educate
someone else because once you raise
their level of consciousness and you
have them see you know a different
perspective that paradigm shift would
allow them to know take advantage of new
opportunities you know once the minds
expanded to new dimensions and over goes
back to its old ways and a lot of that
requires the information Highway to be
right there for everybody so I like the
idea of like having maybe no ceiling on
the amount of wealth people can accrue
because we don't want to put ceilings up
there but but what we can say is that
now people there are people that still
live without clean water clean food
clean shelter we need to make a minimum
a minimal threshold for people to have
clean water clean food clean air clean
home etc and there's but another
question that a lot of what the
sustainable development goals are aiming
at but check this out one of the things
that we can't seem to figure out is how
to achieve that minimum threshold
because funneling money down words
exactly so we need to think about how to
do it and find that solution well giving
people aid is not going to solve your
problem you know they say you know give
a man a fish you feed him for a day you
know teach the man to fish you feed him
for a lifetime and I think that is that
is the what we should take away we
really have to you know flip that switch
yes giving people aid
it might solve a problem in a very short
term in the long term you creates a
cycle of dependency yes people just
cannot you know help themselves soon I
think we all have a responsibility to
get up and get that's what we're given
these gifts for to get up again so then
what's the resource to give up and get
to get up and get what's the what's the
resource that needs to be a funnel or
that needs to be given what is that
resource that needs to be there for the
bare minimum in order for them to be
able to thrive it is equal access to
opportunity
yes that's it but what is it about equal
access opportunity is it how do we
provide an information highway to every
single child around the place yes that
is one of the frameworks so
democratizing information is key giving
them access I mean in sums I mean a
computer well not just a computer I will
because a computer is my hardware yeah
it's the content I'm giving them access
to content that's that's that's it yeah
yeah being very clear we learnt by
giving them the hardware yeah and
nothing happens yes I've seen I've seen
people have hardware even even access to
Internet and they're online watching
porn and a whole bunch of and nothing
really means cat videos instead of
physics videos you need to give them
content so yeah all those things are
true you could say the infrastructure
but you need to give them content and
rich quality content for them to have
that transformation happen I love it
this is this is exactly what we need to
be talking about I'm really happy that
we're talking about this right now thank
you ok so ok
a couple last questions is do you think
that we are alone in the cosmos no no I
don't think so that's a trick yeah
that's a trick question because I think
it's it's individual so we know what I
believe
I personally believe we're not alone in
the cosmos I believe we have
out there there's supernatural beings
out there I probably even believe
there's a another universe out there you
know so yeah I think but also one of the
things is I think we're all connected
spiritually mm-hmm so disconnecting that
context of spirit is is difficult
because we're all really are spiritual
beings at the end of the day and I think
it's also critical for our development
to tap into our inner spiritual being
being able to have that even communicate
or whatever you believe in is really
critical I'm Christian so I would always
defer to my face and and the belief I
have you know in in God and so on while
others might not necessarily agree with
you know what I believe in but then
ultimately I think all religions all
have that same consciousness of they
believe there's a supernatural being and
we believe we're in the cosmos and we're
all connected in some way the connection
between us is very ethereal it's divine
it's gorgeous is amazing yeah okay so
now the this leads us into the next
question which is do you believe there's
a designer to the universe yes I do and
then and then and then what does that it
is that design what does a designer look
like how did that designer make this
well I believe there's a designer I do
believe I'm also I'm also modeled this
designer looks like me I think we're all
designers well my belief is we're all
created in the supernatural being and we
all reflect reflection of that so all of
us have the capacity to design an ocular
that's why we designed that's why we
innovate so I can't say how we were
created but I do know the same skills
are also in every one of us to design
and architect our life and our future
our businesses and everything we do
all right last question what do you
think the most beautiful thing in the
world
oh my god my son oh okay he won't say
beautiful he's really handsome but I
think I think being a mother is the most
beautiful thing ever because you're able
to see in your life be able to take care
of this new life mm-hmm it's it's a lot
of responsibility and also it makes me
appreciate my own mother and I remember
and look at my whole ancestry and really
really appreciate life so I think I love
that I love that yeah yeah that's well
that's what it it's the beauty of
molding a new mind into the world is
that you get to appreciate what your
mother did for you and how it's heaven
doing so she's still my mother is 81
she's gonna be 82 in August
my son is 19 so I've actually you know
seeing him turn into a young man yes and
it's the transitions are just awesome
and you know went from me
being this K take her from me actually
now starting to step back and allow him
to live independence make his it's you
know a trip it's her mom went through
the show my mom went through the same
and I understand her better now I fight
with her all the time
she lives with me and for as long as I
remember we've had this tension every
single day like we mean we we always
fight and she's my best friend
yes yeah I fight over her every single
day I want to make a shout out to the
Mamas to the unconditional love that
many mothers do pass on to their kids
much love to my mother to your mother
and we just passed father's day as well
so happy active to the father's as well
shape us as well so yes so much love to
everybody thank you for tuning in to
this episode this has been a lot of fun
I really appreciate everything that
we've done
you're having me here okay where are you
coming from
you're good you're great answers to the
question you had great answers and
you're working on truly crucial progress
for our future thank you thank you all
do let's let's get there together let's
set up more of these crypto fund
managers across the world that are able
to focus on social impact on a global a
global impact innovation okay much love
everybody if you guys had a good time
make sure to share this content with two
people have them share it with two
people let's get the word out subscribe
comment below with your thoughts we'll
have some links in the bio also join us
on patreon we're trying to scale this
content to more people we're trying to
build it up to football stadiums so we
can fill whole sports stadiums filled
with people yes we're gonna get there
too big they forget where we're nobody
over nobody we're a little speck of dust
trying to make it bad for now but this
is growth mm-hmm hope so thanks
everybody thank you